[Música]
inicia la gira de Anthony blinken Por
medio oriente el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos llegó al Cairo y también
visitará Jerusalén en medio de la ola de
violencia entre israelíes y palestinos y
la atención por los desacuerdos entre
Washington y el gobierno de Israel
la división de homicidios de la policía
de Perú Investiga la muerte de un
manifestante en Lima durante una
protesta contra el gobierno con Nelson
ya 58 las víctimas mortales
organizaciones defensoras de Derechos
Humanos denuncian el uso de armas de
guerra contra los civiles
en Brasil integrantes de la comunidad
indígena yanomami empiezan a recibir
ayuda luego de que el gobierno nacional
declarara la emergencia médica a raíz
del reporte de niños muriéndose a causa
de desnutrición y otras enfermedades
ocasionadas por la minería ilegal de oro
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos medio
oriente el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinken llegó al
Cairo este domingo en la que fue su
primera parada en su gira por medio
oriente y en medio de una escalada de
violencia entre israelíes y palestinos
blinken visitará Jerusalén el lunes y se
convertirá en el segundo funcionario
estadounidense en viajar a Israel este
año después del asesor de seguridad
nacional Jake Sullivan la administración
biden está preocupada por la composición
del gobierno del Primer Ministro
Benjamín netanyahu que incluye a varios
políticos de extrema derecha y que se
oponen a las políticas estadounidenses
en la región entre ellas la que
contempla la resolución de dos estados
el análisis con lluís Muñoz
en los últimos días funerales en Israel
por la muerte violenta de siete personas
en una sinagoga de Jerusalén este y
también en los territorios palestinos
después de un operativo israelí en
jenning que acabó con la vida De 10
personas Israel y las autoridades
palestinas han visto una escalada en sus
relaciones incluyendo la ruptura en
cooperación en materia de seguridad en
ese contexto llega el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos Anthony blinken
a la región queremos que las partes no
cesen la cooperación en materia de
seguridad sino que realmente mejoren la
coordinación en materia de seguridad
instamos a la desescalada y a la calma
de la situación
la administración vaivén llegó al poder
con el objetivo de dejar atrás 20 años
de protagonismo internacional de medio
oriente para enfocarse en Rusia y China
sin embargo ante los últimos
acontecimientos buscan evitar que la
situación entre Israel y las autoridades
palestinas se salga de control es la
visita de más alto nivel desde que
Benjamín netanyahu retomó el poder hace
Estados Unidos quiere mantener a Israel
como su mayor Aliado en el mundo Pero
existe preocupación en Washington por el
gobierno israelí más a la ultraderecha
de la historia entre los temas a tratar
la voluntad de miembros del gobierno de
anexionartis Jordania y una polémica
reforma judicial con netanyahu envuelto
en varios escándalos de corrupción un
equilibrio difícil ya que Estados Unidos
también quiere salvar la estabilidad con
las autoridades palestinas reivindicando
nuevamente la solución de dos estados
algo que parece difícil del mismo modo
que sucede con su otra apuesta para la
región de revivir el acuerdo nuclear de
2015 con Irán por lo que el viaje de
blingen tendrá como objetivo mantener la
situación bajo control
en otras noticias de Estados Unidos el
expresidente Donald Trump dio el
pistoletazo de salida a su candidatura a
la Casa Blanca en 2024 comparadas en New
hampshire y Carolina del Sur marcando
las primeras apariciones en campaña
desde que anunció sus intenciones de
volver a la presidencia hace más de dos
meses un flojo comienzo de campaña había
dejado a muchos cuestionando su
compromiso de volver a presentarse
Donald Trump se apresuró a dejar eso de
lado durante sus dos primeros mítines
decían no está haciendo campaña esto es
como hace un mes cuando lo anuncié bueno
dije ya sabes tengo dos años Ahora estoy
más enfadado y más comprometido que
nunca unos pocos cientos de acérrimos
partidarios de Trump se presentaron en
Carolina del Sur el expresidente cuenta
con ellos para impulsar su tercera
candidatura a la casa blanca estos
votantes ven la presidencia de biden
como algo pasajero
hay muchos demócratas que ven Lo que
pasa en Washington o en todo el país y
se dan cuenta de que quizá no era tan
malo
en su papel de hombre corriente Trump
también pasó por un local de comida
rápida a tomar un helado su mensaje
sigue siendo soy uno de vosotros
solo hay un presidente que ha desafiado
a todo el establishment de Washington y
con su voto el año que viene lo
volveremos a hacer
Trump es el único republicano que ha
anunciado su candidatura hasta ahora
pero no será el último se dice que el
Gobernador de Florida ronde santis la
exgobernadora de Carolina del Sur Nicky
Haley el ex vicepresidente Mike pence
están sopesando sus candidaturas para
diferenciarse Trump ha vuelto a viejos
temas favoritos como la migración están
enviando a personas que son asesinas
asesinas están enviando violadores están
enviando francamente terroristas o
terroristas que vienen por su cuenta y
no podemos permitir que esto suceda nada
se deja al azar ni siquiera la música
Dios bendiga a Estados Unidos pero los
mayores obstáculos para hacerse con la
nominación del partido republicano
pueden ser sus crecientes problemas
legales en particular sobre su papel en
la insurrección de 2021 y sus intentos
de anular su derrota electoral de 2020
vamos a Perú ante la negativa del
Congreso de adelantar elecciones la
presidenta Dina boluarte advirtió a los
legisladores que si vuelven a rechazar
la propuesta su gobierno presentará dos
proyectos de reforma constitucional el
primero Busca celebrar los comicios este
mismo año y el otro que se reforme la
Carta Magna de 1993 de otro lado ya son
58 las víctimas mortales durante las
protestas contra boluarte en casi dos
meses organismos de derechos humanos y
medios de comunicación locales denuncian
el uso de armas de guerra en contra de
los manifestantes
armamento militar y una brutal represión
a medida que aumenta el número de
muertos y heridos durante el estallido
social el último Víctor Santi Esteban
quien falleció el sábado después de
recibir un impacto en la cabeza con un
proyectil lanzado por la policía como se
ve en este video publicado por el medio
local independiente huaica no fue una
piedra la causa de muerte solo lo puede
determinar el examen médico legal la
necropsia de ley pero como se puede
apreciar en el video whiteca Perú
claramente se ve el disparo de una bomba
a lacrimógena a corta distancia a la
cabeza de Víctor en medio de
comunicación peruano ojo público revela
una investigación donde apuntan a que
las fuerzas del orden habrían usado
armas de fuego letales como fusil HK un
arma de asalto de guerra para disuadir
las manifestaciones anti gubernamentales
que van a entrar en su segundo mes una
serie de necropsias e informes
balísticos obtenidos por ojo público que
forman parte de la investigación fiscal
por homicidio calificado confirman
muertas de personas no todos eran
manifestantes por armas de uso militar
manif y Defensores de Derechos Humanos
tildados como terroristas por la
presidenta Dina boluarte han denunciado
el uso de perdigones balas y otros
proyectiles lanzados indiscriminadamente
por los uniformados contra los cuerpos
de las personas que están protestando en
las calles y nosotros este saludamos la
vida de muchas personas porque nosotros
agarramos la bomba y metemos al agua con
bicarbonato y anulamos la normativa
peruana prohíbe el uso de armas de
guerra para controlar manifestaciones y
los organismos de Derechos Humanos
internacionales exigen al ejecutivo
peruano el cese de la violencia policial
y el respeto de la protesta pacífica la
comunidad llanomami en Brasil empieza a
recibir ayuda por parte de
organizaciones sociales y empresas de
aeronáutica que pueden desplazarse hasta
la amazonía para evacuar a los enfermos
luego de que el gobierno de Lula da
Silva decretara la emergencia de salud
pública en el territorio ahora la
prioridad es atender a menores como
malnutrición malaria y otras
enfermedades desatendidas durante el
mandato de Jair bolsonaro
empieza a llegar la ayuda a la comunidad
llanomami de Brasil después de que el
gobierno de Lula da Silva decretara el
pasado 20 de enero la emergencia de
salud pública en la región amazónica
algunas compañías aéreas comenzaron a
llegar al territorio para evacuar
enfermos muchos de ellos menores para
poder acceder a tratamientos médicos se
necesitan avionetas y helicópteros por
lo que 40 pistas de aterrizaje
permanecen activas
la tierra indígena tiene más de 30.000
personas y se necesita transporte aéreo
tanto para evacuar a los Indígenas
enfermos como para traer víveres
la salud de los Llanos mami la comunidad
indígena más grande de Brasil se ha
deteriorado en los últimos años debido a
la minería presente en tierras fértiles
que contamina ríos y otras fuentes de
agua como consecuencia enfermedades como
la malaria se han disparado en los
últimos dos años con más de 44.000 casos
según datos oficiales otras condiciones
infecciosas como gripe o anemias también
se pueden convertir en mortales por la
falta de recursos
sabemos que en los últimos años la
situación ha empeorado hasta llegar al
punto donde estamos ahora
además al menos 570 menores murieron
durante el mandato del ultraderechista
Jair bolsonaro que potenció las
actividades extractivistas y dejó de
lado a la comunidad empuje cuatro años
desde hace cuatro años solo estamos
llorando la comunidad de luto los niños
enfermos el pasado jueves 26 de enero la
Corte Suprema emitía un comunicado en el
que ponía de relieve la dejación de
funciones del expresidente un extremo
que ahora Lula da Silva quiere revertir
hasta que es informativo en France 24
Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]